-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
This weekend was
Easter, Passover, and Ramadan.
It's what's known
in the religious community
as a Holy Turducken.
I do love Easter Sunday, though.
It's the day parents give
their kids a basket of candy
then tell them
to sit quietly at church.
It's just very interesting.
Speaking of Easter,
today the Bidens hosted
the first White House
Easter Egg Roll
since the pandemic began,
and it was a huge event
with 30,000 people
in attendance.
Yep, after two minutes
of rolling eggs across the lawn,
the kids were like,
"Wow, I actually miss Zoom."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
I was thrilled to be invited
and attend this year's
Easter Egg Roll.
I did. I was there.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Today. This morning.
I told President Biden
it was an honor
and a privilege to be there
and he said, "Uh, Jimmy,
we invited 30,000 people."
[ Laughter ]
But I actually did get to go
to the White House today, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
When they said, "The president
wants to see you,"
I thought, "Damn, how bad
did I screw up my taxes?"
But I had an absolute blast.
Plus, good news --
during the egg hunt,
I found Trump's missing
call logs from January 6th.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
I found them.
[ Applause ]
I really did have the best time.
Do we have a photo of me
with the president?
Yeah, unbelievable.
It was great.
Actually, I read my book
"Nana Loves You More"
to all the kids.
Yeah, and --
[ Cheering and applause ]
With the president
and the first lady
right next to me.
This is a real photo of this
from this morning. Yeah.
[ Audience awws ]
Yeah.
While I was reading to the kids,
the first lady was so sweet.
She was like, "Sound it out,
Jimmy. You can do it."
Meanwhile,
I saw that, for Easter,
a photo of some knockoff
Dollar Store Peeps went viral.
So it's Dollar Store Peeps.
Take a look at these things,
this photo.
Wow.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Looks like Peeps that appeared
in an episode of "Botched."
[ Laughter ]
Looks like "The Real Housewives
of Marshmallowy Hills."
Let's switch gears.
As you hopefully already know,
today is tax day.
That's right. It's tax day.
Did you know that?
[ Scattered reaction ]
Alright. It was kind of
a non-reaction, though.
Like, "Yeah, uh, okay."
Yeah, it is tax day,
it's a pandemic, it's spring.
So you can get taxed,
vaxxed, and waxed.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell it's tax day
'cause right now
every billionaire
is laying low in space.
[ Laughter ]
Well, ahead of today's
tax deadline,
the White House released
the Bidens' tax return,
and, together,
they earned over $600,000.
Making Joe Biden
the Jeff Bezos
of Wilmington, Delaware.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the President made money
from his salary, his book sales,
and his upcoming cameo
in "Magic Mike 3."
Well, according
to their tax return,
the Bidens did not receive
a refund this year.
When he saw, even Biden
was like, "Friggin' Biden."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Unbelievable."
But this is cool --
the FDA just authorized
the first ever
COVID breath test.
It's more than 90% effective.
Check out what this
breathalyzer looks like.
This is real.
Yeah.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's amazing.
The guy combined luggage
with a Capri Sun.
Ah, it's amazing.
Now there's nasal swabs
and breathalyzers,
which means pretty soon
you'll see two lines at CVS,
one that says, "Up Yours,"
the other one says, "Blow Me."
-Hey! Whoa!
[ Rimshot ]
Whoa!
[ Applause ]
-Well, here in New York today
former Mayor Michael Bloomberg
spoke at City Hall
and people were saying
that his mask
seemed too tight for his face.
Look at this.
-But, seriously,
I was glad to have the chance
to welcome back each of my
predecessors to City Hall
and I'm glad that you're
-You can see his lips.
-carrying on that tradition.
[ Laughter ]
-He spoke for about 10 more
seconds then passed out.
Can we see that again?
Yeah.
It's like in his mouth.
[ Mumbling ]
Who makes his mask?
Lululemon makes his mask.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-You know that under that mask,
he looked like
a Dollar Store Peep. Yeah...
[ Muffled shouting ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone's
talking about this.
A federal judge has overruled
the CDC's mask mandate
for planes
and now all the major airlines
have dropped their
mask requirements.
But don't worry,
to keep everyone safe,
you can now bring only
up to 3.4 ounces
of COVID onboard.
-Oh.
-That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
To put it another way,
airlines are basically
turning off the seatbelt sign
for COVID
and telling it to move freely
about the cabin.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, if you thought
Omicron was bad,
wait till you meet
the Spirit variant.
[ Laughter ]
Whoo!
-Whoo!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-When the news broke,
some pilots actually
announced the news midflight,
and people started celebrating.
This is true.
Yeah, passengers were dancing,
hugging, kissing,
and now they're all
in quarantine.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there was a crazy scene
on American Airlines.
People tore off their masks
and shoved them
right into the ashtrays.
[ Laughter ]
How old is this plane?
Yeah.
And it's not just planes.
Amtrak has also ended
their mask mandate.
Right now train conductors
are celebrating
by punching 25 tiny holes
in their masks.
[ Imitates punch clicking ]
[ Laughter ]
"Can I have your mask, please?"
[ Imitates punch clicking ]
[ Light laughter ]
Right now also Uber
has announced
that they're dropping
all mask requirements.
Honestly, I'm going to miss
getting into a masked
stranger's car.
It was kind of fun
to play that game --
my ride to the airport
or kidnapping?
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the White House
isn't happy with the ruling.
They called it disappointing
and urged travelers
to keep wearing masks,
but they said that they're
not fighting the decision.
It's kind of like your parents
when you tell them
about your new tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know if you're going
to like 'Suite Life
of Zack and Cody' in 20 years.
But go for it.
Get the tattoo.
Hope for a reunion."
Speaking of the White House,
I read that President Biden
has told former President Obama
that he plans to run
for reelection in 2024.
Biden was like,
"I'll consider the long,
silent stare your blessing."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that was a good one.
Yeah, that's a good joke.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
Obama actually had
some good advice.
He was like, "Be careful.
After two terms,
people might say you look old."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys see this?
French President Emmanuel Macron
is running for reelection,
and a photo of him
is going viral
'cause he's showing
a ton of chest hair.
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Yeah.
There he is.
Well, it's inspired Macron
to test some new
campaign slogans.
Check these out.
First up, there's...
Next up, there's...
-Whoa!
-And finally, there's...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey!
-Oh!
-Hey!
-Macron.
-Apparently the people of France
love the photo
and it's become very popular.
I guess that explains
what I saw earlier today.
-E15 is about 10 cents a gallon
cheaper than E10.
And some gas stations
are offering...
[ Laughter ]
-It works.
I like it.
Approval rating up.
-Yeah.
-Some more news.
Former President Trump
just released a statement
saying that Russia and Ukraine
should try
to reach an agreement
to end the war.
[ Light laughter ]
When they heard that,
Miss America contestants
were like, "Nailed it."
Yeah.
Great answer.
Yep, Trump was like,
"After eight weeks,
I've now come to realize
this is a no bueno."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
this is interesting.
Scientists in Japan
came up with a creative way
to get people to eat less salt.
Check this out.
-Researchers in Japan hope their
new taste-enhancing chopsticks
will make healthy food
low in salt taste better.
The high-tech utensils
are hooked up
to a special computer device
on the user's wrist,
which causes
a small electric current
to flow
through what they're eating,
activating any sodium ions
and allowing for their tongue
to taste more salt
than is actually in the food.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow, it's just that simple!
[ Laughter ]
Anyone else see a problem
combining soup and electricity?
[ Laughter ]
If you want to save time, just
pour the soup over your head
and plug yourself into a wall.
I heard about a woman
in Massachusetts
who was learning to drive
in a cemetery
and crashed
into eight headstones.
[ Light laughter ]
It's just weird that her
driving instructor was like,
"Try a U-turn at Edna Doyle's
final resting place
and then parallel park
by the mausoleum."
Yep. So between that and getting
stuck behind a booth,
she had a real tough day.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone
is talking about this.
Netflix just announced that,
for the first time
in over a decade,
they lost subscribers,
and now their stock is crashing.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
Not only did
their stock plummet,
but it turns out that all
the cash they had in the bank
was just cake.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, apparently raising
their subscription fee
every eight seconds
wasn't such a good idea.
Right now Netflix
is so desperate for money,
they're now Googling "Is there
a real life 'Squid Game'?"
It's sad.
Netflix is blaming their losses
on fierce competition,
inflation, and Russia.
When he heard that,
President Biden was like,
"Hey, get your own excuses.
That's..."
But now Netflix says
they're open to launching
lower-priced streaming plans
with ads.
[ Audience groans ]
That's right.
Entertainment with commercials.
It's an innovative new concept
called "television."
Very interesting.
Yep, Netflix is losing money.
You can tell it's having
an effect on all of their shows.
For instance, "Emily in Paris"
is now
"Emily in Pittsburgh."
-Oh.
-It's still good, but, yeah.
-Wow.
-Also, "The Crown" is now
"The Hat."
And finally, "Bridgerton" is now
"American Girl Dolls Being
Rubbed Against Each Other
With Human Hands."
[ Applause ]
I'll still watch it, but...
Well, this is nice.
I read that, next month,
President Biden is returning
to his alma mater,
the University of Delaware,
to deliver
the commencement speech.
Yep, freshmen
are actually invited
to this graduation because,
when Biden's done speaking,
they'll be seniors.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
But I'm sure Biden's address
will inspire kids,
especially when he says,
"I'm living proof that,
if you follow your dreams,
you can achieve them.
In 60 years."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw that the CDC has
officially launched a new center
that will forecast outbreaks
of infectious diseases.
It raises a lot
of questions like, uh,
"Isn't that what they did?"
I mean...
That's what the CDC does, right?
It feels sort of like
CNN launching CNN+.
It's like, "Wait. What are we --
What are we doing here?" Yeah.
Listen to this.
Today Vin Diesel announced
that the title of the next
"Fast and Furious" movie
is "Fast X."
[ Audience oohs ]
It actually sounds like
an over-the-counter laxative.
[ Laughter ]
-Zoink!
[ Drumbeat ]
-It actually sounds like
a FedEx knockoff
where a guy named Dennis
shows up with your package.
"Hey, you ordered Fast X?"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this, everyone.
NASA just released a new report
where they say
their biggest priority is
probing Uranus.
-Ohh.
Come on.
-Higgins, do you want --
Do you know anything
about Uranus?
-Well, I know it's the seventh
planet from the sun.
-Interesting.
-It's also the third-largest
planet in the solar system.
It's almost four times larger
than Earth.
-That's it?
-Um...
It also reminds me of,
you know, "your anus,"
you know, like, the words.
-Yeah, that's what I --
-Is it the Red Planet?
No, it's a brown planet, right?
Uranus?
-I-I wouldn't know.
Are you talking about Uranus,
as a whole?
-Yeah.
Not a black hole, though.
That's a different...
-Yeah, different thing.
-...celestial body.
-Thank you.
Well, guys, today is 4/20,
and oddly enough, tomorrow...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah. Happy 4/20, everyone.
Tomorrow --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oddly enough, tomorrow,
the sale of recreational weed
will begin in New Jersey.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah. That's right.
One day after 4/20.
I mean, really?
That's like Chipotle offering
free guac on Seis de Mayo.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, police say that a man
in West Virginia was arrested
after he was pulled over,
and instead of handing
officers his registration,
he gave them his meth.
[ Laughter ]
His lawyer was like,
"Your Honor -- I got nothing.
I..."
And, finally,
did you guys see the picture
of French President
Emmanuel Macron
that was going around yesterday?
It went viral
because his shirt is unbuttoned
and he's showing
a lot of chest hair.
Here it is.
Here it is right -- Yeah.
-Whoa.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Yeah, well, Macron is running
for reelection right now,
and he actually asked us
if he could premiere
a new campaign song
on our show tonight.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome French President
Emmanuel Macron.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ French accent ]
♪ Bonjour, it is me ♪
♪ With my chest hair, you see ♪
♪ Do you think I'm sexy? ♪
♪ I sure hope you say oui ♪
♪ I have good policies
for ze economy ♪
♪ I shall make my VP
Emily in Paris ♪
♪ I'm as French as can be ♪
♪ I can get you in free ♪
♪ To ze patisserie ♪
♪ The chef is Ratatouille ♪
♪ We can nibble ze brie ♪
♪ Smoke a cig by the sea ♪
♪ Give my chest hair a squeeze ♪
♪ As it blows in ze breeze ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Now I must say adieu ♪
♪ But in twenty twenty-deux ♪
♪ If you all vote for me,
I will whisper... ♪
♪ Merci ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ But for now I bid you ♪
♪ Adieu, adieu ♪
♪ Adieu ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you. That applause lasted
longer than CNN+.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
If you haven't heard, today
it was announced that
the streaming service CNN+
is shutting down just 32 days
after it launched.
That's right, CNN+ is gone,
which means in six months,
it'll be turned into
Spirit Halloween+.
[ Laughter ]
32 days, oh, my --
I've had avocados
that last longer than that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was doing so badly,
all they had to do was call
their one subscriber like,
"Hey, Doug, we're not going to
do this."
[ Laughter ]
You could tell this was
on the horizon though when CNN
had a CNN countdown clock
to the end of CNN+.
It was very interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's get to some news
or what we think might be news.
Did you guys see this?
Piers Morgan interviewed
former President Trump,
and he released a promo that
shows Trump storming out
after refusing to admit
that he lost the election.
But now Trump is claiming
that he never stormed out
and that Piers Morgan actually
doctored the footage.
[ Laughter ]
In Trump's defense,
I really don't see him
"storming" anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
If you haven't seen the clip,
here it is.
-I don't think you're real.
Very dishonest.
Let's finish up the interview.
Turn the camera off.
Very dishonest.
[ Laughter ]
-My only question is has Trump
been living at Mar-a-Lago
or under a heat lamp
at Golden Corral?
[ Laughter ]
I was wondering.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I was wondering that.
He's done!
-Nice.
-Flip him over!
-Texas toast.
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of crazy things on TV,
last night was a new episode of
"The Masked Singer,"
and the jack-in-the-box
was revealed to be
Rudy Giuliani.
Watch this.
-Oh, my goodness!
Former associate
attorney general --
-Oh, my God.
-Former mayor of New York City,
Rudy Giuliani!
-♪ I'm here to tell you, honey ♪
♪ That I'm bad to the bone ♪
♪ Bad to the bone ♪
♪ Bad, real bad, very bad ♪
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it actually takes
talent not to hit any notes.
I think that's
actually interesting.
[ Laughter ]
After seeing that, the CDC
reinstated the mask mandate.
They're like,
"Put the mask back on now.
Now we're putting the mask
back on."
That's right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
"Just put it -- For all of us."
Well, this was nuts.
Last night, the Army --
the Army dropped parachutists
into the Washington Nationals'
baseball stadium,
but the FAA forgot to tell
the Capitol it was happening,
so they thought the plane
was a threat
and evacuated the Capitol.
[ Audience laughs, gasps ]
Come on, you can't sneak up
on the Capitol like that!
That's like throwing
a surprise party for someone
who just had a heart attack.
It's like, "Hey!"
You can't do that!
[ Laughter ]
Thankfully, everything was fine
until Nancy Pelosi got back
and was like, "Damn it, who the
hell took my podium again?
Alright, come on now.
This is not funny."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, get this.
Apparently a source close
to Bernie Sanders said that he
might run for president in 2024
if Joe Biden doesn't.
So I guess the Democratic ticket
in 2024
is between the Muppets
in the balcony.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Statler 2024!"
Hey, here's some good news.
Today is Queen Elizabeth's
96th birthday.
Hey!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Happy birthday.
And to celebrate,
the royal family posted
a brand-new photo of her.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
Wow, the new "Game of Thrones"
spinoff looks great.
I think it's --
[ Laughter ]
Who knows?
I'm telling you, she's got
to stop feeding the corgis.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Looks like she's starring
in a Budweiser commercial.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the queen turned 96 today,
and we wanted to wish her
a happy birthday
the only way we know how.
So without further ado,
please welcome
the wait staff from the
Times Square Applebee's.
Come on out, guys.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Applebee's is fun,
it's true ♪
-♪ Especially when we sing
for you ♪
-♪ Good news is
we sing for free ♪
-♪ Bad news is we sing off-key ♪
-♪ Sound off ♪
-♪ Happy ♪
-♪ Birthday ♪
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you very much, guys.
Good to see you, everybody.
Thank you for being here.
That was good. Not bad.
That's the real --
-Aw, such a thrill.
-Times Square Applebee's, go get
their autograph tonight, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, people are talking
about this.
In Florida, a bride and wedding
caterer have been arrested
for allegedly lacing the lasagna
at her wedding with cannabis.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Don't clap for that.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
-People were suspicious
after watching the bride
and groom
feed each other
the entire wedding cake.
[ Laughter ]
That definitely explains why
the father-daughter dance
was to a four-hour
Grateful Dead bootleg.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I heard about a man
in North Carolina who robbed
a Dollar Store, regretted it,
and then returned all the cash.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, apparently the guy looked
around the store and said,
"You know,
I think you guys need this
more than I do."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a 21-year-old
Chihuahua has officially claimed
the title of the world's
oldest dog.
The dog is so old,
he fetches a tennis ball,
and then puts it on the bottom
of his walker.
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Today is Earth Day.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, everyone is trying
to do their part.
As we speak,
CNN is properly disposing
of CNN+.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of Earth Day,
I saw that President Biden
visited Seattle
and signed an executive order
to safeguard old-growth forests.
That's great. Can we see
an old-growth forest?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, look at that chest hair.
Yeah, that's nice.
Look at that chest hair.
-Ooh la la.
-[ French accent ] Oh, am I
sexy enough for you?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah.
While Biden was in Seattle,
he also spoke about the need
for using clean energy
and he even demonstrated
how powerful windmills can be.
Watch this.
[ Whirring ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
They are powerful.
Ahead of Earth Day,
Apple announced that it is using
more recycled materials
to make its products
than ever before.
Yeah, recycled iPhones.
It's weird when you turn on your
new iPhone and Siri says --
-I used to be a Shake Weight.
-Okay.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, the second weekend
of Coachella just kicked off
and I heard that,
since the first weekend,
COVID cases in the area
have gone up by 77%.
[ Oohs and ohs ]
Everyone there is like,
"I can't believe
this is happening
when we're doing everything
we're not supposed to do!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Tony Awards are coming up
and they just issued
a strict no-violence policy...
[ Laughter ]
...to potential ticket buyers.
That's right, the Tonys,
no violence.
No violence, yeah.
Because you can always tell
a fight's going to break out
at the Tonys
when people start snapping.
[ Snapping fingers ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Hey, boy ♪
♪♪
I appreciate it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Water?
-Oxygen?
-Some business news --
I read that the CEO of Old Navy
is stepping down.
Now, Old Navy's going to try on
a dozen new CEOs
before finding one that fits
and leaving the rest
on the floor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's very interesting.
And, finally, this weekend,
two stunt pilots will attempt
the first ever plane swap.
This is where they're going
to fly close together,
go into a nosedive,
then jump into each other's
planes before landing.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Yeah, it'll be the one time
the pilot actually deserves
applause for landing the plane.